مستشفى سان أنطونيو ميثوديست ، تحتاج رئتي
طفل يبلغ من العمر 29 عامًا أصيبت بأضرار بالغة من جراء
فيروس كورونا إلى إجراء مسح للقطط للمرضى الذين يعانون من
أمراض خطيرة للغاية ، ما يجب أن يكون سهلاً يتطلب
تنسيقًا هائلاً وجيشًا صغيرًا
فقط لنقلهم من الألف إلى
الياء.  الكود الذي لم
نتجاوزه حتى الآن ، لكنه
ساحق الآن ومن المتوقع أن
يزداد سوءًا في الأيام المقبلة
، شهدت مقاطعة الدب في سان أنطونيو
ارتفاعًا حادًا في النسبة المئوية لأولئك الذين
ثبتت إصابتهم بالفيروس
في آخر 30 يومًا فقط من المتوسط الأسبوعي لـ
لقد انتقل هؤلاء الذين ثبتت إصابتهم من 3.6 في
المائة إلى أكثر من 20 في المائة ، لذا فإن العديد من
الإصابات تزداد إصابة الأمهات
بفيروس كورونا لدى
مستشفى ميثوديست الآن وحدة مخصصة في وحدة
العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة للأطفال المولودين لأمهات
لديهن تلك الصورة التي تريدها كل أم.
الطفل الذي يولد ويحمل الطفل
يحدث ذلك مع الأطفال وكوفات
للأسف لا يتعين علينا ذلك
بمجرد ولادة الطفل ويقومون بإحضارهم
مباشرة إلينا خارج  الباب ، لذا فهي
مجرد لحظة وجيزة جدًا قد تحصل فيها الأم
على لمحة في الرحم ،
لا ينتقل الفيروس عادةً من
الأم إلى الطفل ، ولكن أثناء عملية الولادة
، يرتفع خطر الإصابة بالعدوى
ويعالج الأطفال حديثي الولادة بفيروس كورونا
أكثر تعقيدًا.  على الرغم من أن
نتائج اختبار هؤلاء الأطفال سلبية ، إلا أنهم يعاملون على
أنهم يرتدون عمال رعاية صحية إيجابيين مشتبه بهم
يرتدون معدات الوقاية الشخصية الكاملة ، ويتم فصل هؤلاء الأطفال
المولودين لأمهات مصابات بفيروس كورونا
عن الآخرين فقط في
حالة إنجابك لخمسة أطفال هنا الآن ،
نعم لديك مساحة لـ 16  نعم ، هل
تعتقد أنك ستكون ممتلئًا ، أفعل
بالطريقة التي تسير بها الأمور التي نعترف بها
كثيرًا ، نعم ،
كريستي لا فيسينا ، تبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا فقط ،
تتوقع أن يكون طفلها الرابع هي
وخطيبها مصابون بفيروس كورونا
بشكل أساسي  كانت عظامي تؤلمني
فقط لم أستطع الاستلقاء ، لقد كان
يؤذي عظامك فقط عظامي من
حملي بشدة بما فيه الكفاية دون
أن تتخذ الاحتياطات ولا تعرف كيف
حصلت عليها الآن  فقط آمل أن تتعافى
وأن أطفالها الثلاثة
وخطيبتها خالية من فيروس كورونا بحلول الوقت الذي
ولدت فيه في غضون شهر تقريبًا ، أنا متوتر للغاية ،
فأنا امرأة قوية جدًا أميل
إلى فعل الكثير ، والآن لا يمكنني القيام بذلك.
تحتاج إلى المساعدة في أنها تلحق خسائر فادحة ،
ربما تشهد مستشفى ميثوديست
بداية زيادة حادة على مستوى البلاد
في عدد الأمهات المصابات بفيروس كورونا اللائي يلدن ،
هناك في الواقع بعض المؤلفات المتوفرة
لدعمها بمعدل 30٪
بدون أعراض بحيث كانت 30٪
معدلات عديمة الأعراض للأمهات  قادمة من
الأمهات القادمات في فترة الحمل وفيروس كورونا ،
قطعة واحدة فقط من مستشفى ميثوديست الوبائي الذي
يعالج موجة متزايدة من
المرضى المصابين بأمراض خطيرة في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية كانت ساحقة ، كيف
يمكنني أن أصف أنه كان هناك المزيد
والمزيد من المرضى أكثر مما نعرف حقًا
ماذا  فيما يتعلق بالمرضى ، أصبحوا
أصغر سنًا وأصبحوا أكثر مرضًا وأصغر بكثير ،
فمن
المحتمل أن تكون في الخمسينيات والستينيات من القرن الماضي
للموجة الأولى حتى فقدت المسار  20 شخصًا
في العشرينات من العمر ،
هذه وحدة ميثوديست كوفات اثنين ، إنها
واحدة من ثلاث وحدات كوفا متخصصة
في غرف المرضى بالمستشفى مغلقة
كل واحدة تحولت إلى غرف ضغط سلبي ،
لذلك يحتاج الموظفون فقط إلى فجر معدات الوقاية الشخصية
إذا ذهبوا إلى أحد الخلجان التي
لديهم  14 غرفة ، عدد 14 غرفة
مليئة بقائمة انتظار ، ما هي المدة التي تستغرقها هذه
القائمة
، لقد طالت مدة إنشاء المستشفى لمزيد من
الأسرة ، لكن في الوقت الحالي ، كان هذا هو المكان الذي يتم فيه
علاج أكثر المرضى مرضًا
بالأمس ، ربما كان أحد أسوأ
الأيام التي مررت بها على الإطلاق  كان
لدي سبب تلقيي 10 مكالمات ، وجميعهم من
الشباب الذين سيكونون
مرشحين ممتازين ليكونوا قادرين على تقديم ECMO
، فهم مرضى لدرجة
أنهم إذا لم يحصلوا على هذا الدعم ،
فمن المحتمل أن يكونوا  سأموت ، كان لدي ثلاثة
أسرة ، وفقط في اتخاذ هذا القرار ، فإن
القدرة على معرفة من الذي
سيستفيد منه حقًا هو مستوى من
اتخاذ القرار لا أعتقد أن
الكثير منا مستعد لتلك المكالمات
القادمة من  مستشفيات أخرى عبر سو
تكساس مع مرضى مرضى لدرجة أن
ميثوديست قد يكون أملهم الأخير
يستخدم مستشفى ميثوديست إجراءً
لتزويد الدم بالأكسجين وإبقاء المرضى
بعيدًا عن أجهزة التنفس الصناعي ، يطلق عليه اسم ECMO أو
أكسجة الغشاء خارج الجسم
اليوم د.  يقوم دي لا فولبي بإدخال
أنابيب كبيرة في عروق طفل يبلغ من العمر 33 عامًا
يجرون من أعلى الفخذ إلى
القلب حيث يخرج الدم من الجسم
مؤكسجًا ميكانيكيًا ثم
يعود إلى القلب على الفور تقريبًا كان
الفريق الميثودي لديه  الكثير من
الممارسة العملية تستغرق بضع دقائق فقط ،
فهي تنطوي على القدرة على أخذ
كانيولا كبيرة هناك ، فهي تشبه
خراطيم الحدائق الصغيرة تقريبًا كما
وصفتها ، يجب أن تكون قادرة على
ضخ حوالي جالونين أو ثلاثة جالونات من الدم
في الدقيقة من خلال  لذلك فإن أحدهما يقوم
بإفراغ الدم
والآخر يعيد الدم الخارج
من المريض مظلمًا ويبدو
غير صحي ، فالدم العائد أحمر فاتح
محمل بالأكسجين على الفور تقريبًا
، ويعود مستوى الأكسجين في دم المريض
إلى ما يقرب من المعدل الطبيعي.  فرصة
النجاة الآن أفضل مما لو كانوا يستخدمون
جهاز التنفس الصناعي
أعتقد أن جهاز التنفس الصناعي يسبب
الكثير من الضرر ونجد أن هذا
يسبب ضررًا بشكل عام ولكنه يسبب
بالتأكيد  يسبب ضررًا عندما نتحدث عن
مرضى مصابين بكوفان لأن
رئتيهم ضعيفة جدًا لأن
أرجلهم ضعيفة جدًا ولأن
هناك أسبابًا أخرى تجعل المرضى
يواجهون مشكلة في دفع أجهزة التنفس الصناعي
الأكسجين إلى الرئتين إلى
الرئتين التالفتين وهذا  حسنًا ، ليس
فقط أنك
تعاني من جميع مشاكل
الأوعية الدموية والتخثر في
الأوعية الدموية ليس فقط أنك تعاني
من جميع مشاكل الأكسجين التي لا
تتمكن من الوصول إلى أعضائك في
أعضائك التي تتوقف عن ذلك ولكن الآن
أنت تدفع الهواء بشكل مصطنع إلى
رئتيك وتتسبب في المزيد من الضرر بهذه
الطريقة ، درسًا صعبًا آخر من الوباء
، ولا يزال مقدمو الرعاية الصحية للفيروس في
كل مكان يكافحون
لفهم أننا لا نفهم تمامًا سبب أداء
شخص لديه قيم معملية لـ X
بشكل جيد  الشخص الذي لديه قيم معملية
يبدو أنها أفضل لا
يصنعها والقناع ليس طلبًا كبيرًا للمساعدة في إنقاذ
حياتك والعمل والضغط على العاملين في مجال الرعاية
الصحية  rs في كل مكان تتسارع مع
ارتفاع معدلات الإصابة ، يتوقعون
المزيد من العمل والضغط في المستقبل على
المرضى وكذلك المرضى
المنعزلين عن الجميع.
الغرفة ستقودك للجنون في البداية ،
لكنك تجاوزت ذلك ، يعمل مايكل فاسكويز البالغ من العمر 28 عامًا
في أحد المستودعات ، فهو غير
متأكد من كيفية مرضه ، فهو جزء من برنامج جديد
هنا لتنشيط المرضى
والمشي في أسرع وقت ممكن حتى
يساعد قليلاً على الصعيدين الجسدي
والعقلي ما فعلته لرئتيك ،
لقد جعلهما بالفعل يتعبان بشكل سيئ حقًا
ما آسف فاسكيز ليس متأكدًا مما إذا كانت
هناك أي آثار طويلة المدى على
رئتيه في الوقت الحالي ، فهو يركز على
العودة إلى المنزل لزوجته  وابني يبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات
أفتقدك تعرف وجودهما سيدي
كما تعلم السيدة.  تمسك
بزوجتك وتقبّل ابنك ، والذهاب إلى الغرفة
والتأكد من أنه بخير ، أفتقدها كثيرًا ،
نعلم أنه عندما يمشي الناس عندما
ينام الناس بشكل أفضل عندما يرى الناس ضوءًا ساطعًا ،
فإنهم يتحسنون في وقت أقرب ، ونعرف
كل هذا على ما أعتقد.  الاضطرار
إلى إعادة تعلمه مع kovat بسبب
استجابتنا له ، فأنت تعلم بوضوح
حاجتنا للحفاظ على سلامتنا للحفاظ على
سلامة الموظفين ، لذا فليس من
الجزع أننا انتهى بنا الأمر إلى عزل
الناس سواء كنا نعتزم أم لا
درسًا آخر من الوباء يحاول ذلك
تقليل أوقات التعافي وإخلاء الأسرّة التي
تمس الحاجة إليها للطفرة المتزايدة المتوقعة
من الأشخاص المصابين بفيروس كورونا بشكل خطير في
الوقت الحالي ، نحن في
الطابق العلوي لدرجة أننا نواجه بعض التأخير
في نقل المرضى إلى الطابق العلوي لأنه
لا توجد أسرّة مُجهزة
ومستعدون لمرضى الغيبوبة ، لذا
فنحن نحتجز الكثير منهم في
قسم الطوارئ الآن حوالي أربع
ساعات في أربعة أيام ، ما الذي يدفع إلى
زيادة عدد الجنود هنا.  متأكد تمامًا
ولكن بناءً على ما يسمعونه من
المرضى ، كان هناك شعور بأن
الأسوأ كان وراءنا ، ولا أعتقد أن
هناك حادثة واحدة محددة
أدت بالفعل إلى هذا الارتفاع ، أعتقد أن الناس
بعد مارس وأبريل كانوا
محبطين للغاية من التواجد في الداخل
وبمجرد رفع هذه القيود ،
أرادوا الخروج من بعض الأشخاص المحميين
لم يفعلوا ذلك ، والآن نرى فقط
نتيجة ذلك مع
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع القادمة ، الخوف الآن
سيصبح تدفق المرضى
موجة مد.  لا أعتقد أنني رأيت
أي شيء من هذا القبيل على الإطلاق وأود أن أقول
إنه إذا كنت تريد أن ترى الأول من أغسطس ،
فربما يجب عليك البقاء في المنزل
والعزل في الرابع من يوليو ، ميغيل ماركيز سي إن إن
سان أنطونيو تكساس